Clara Sousa-Silva: I think the public often thinks that
I'm spending my days just kind of
pointing at a star and going "Oh, aliens on that
one! There's definitely." And it's not that.
[Imaging Science]
[Imaging Out Of This World]
[#1 Collecting Enough Light]
You know it's all about getting a really large
lens, effectively. We want just very large
mirrors that are extremely carefully done and
very stable and very large. It becomes a kind
of a crude size problem and you want to focus
that light in and then you can process it. But
the really expensive and really difficult bit of
the setup is getting that lens, that large lens.
And then we also have clouds. So it seems like
everyone here has to deal with clouds. And not
just clouds, but even in a clear atmosphere, our
atmosphere is not visible at all wavelengths,
not transparent at all wavelengths. And so often
we need to go above the earth's atmosphere into
a space telescope. But now if you want a large
mirror, you know the size of a tennis court,
which is kind of what we're aiming for, that's
really hard to put in space. So you end up having
this problem of having slightly smaller lenses
but in space, or bigger lenses but on the ground.
And the combination of the two is really how we
get really good insights into alien atmospheres.
[#2 Photographing Change Over Time]
Curtis Woodcock: Consistent observation is really
important over long periods of time,
very frequently. And what you measure is
important, but it's more how often you measure it
that really comes to light. In our work, we've
really only for about 10 years been able to
do things like grab a thousand images
of the same place and analyze them all
together to try to track the way things are
changing on the surface. And and one of the things
that has emerged is that the more frequently
you look at places the more change you find,
and and that's hard to understand at first because
you'd like to think well, the change is either
there or it isn't there, and and so if you keep
looking more frequently you shouldn't find more
change. But you you start finding different kinds
of change. So there's there's kind of consistent
seasonal patterns that you'll notice. But if you
look very carefully at the seasonal patterns,
they shift from year to year. And so you start,
if you look real frequently, you start to notice
the variability from one year to the next
year. You start to notice the variability in
the climate. So you'll start to see the effect
of droughts, you'll start to see the effect of
particularly rainy years, you'll start to see
whole new different kinds of variability rather
than just people cutting down forests or building
cities or or that kind of thing. And so I've kind
of come to this mantra that you know, the more
frequently you look the more change you find and
it was hard to understand and accept at first,
but that's one of the things I've learned about
the world we live in, relative to the way we
observe it, if you want to think of it that way.
[#3 Clearing the Atmosphere]
It's always a fight with the atmosphere
of the earth and particularly my field,
which is trying to look for the sort of molecules
that could signal life. As you can imagine,
these are molecules we already have in this
atmosphere, and so it's very hard to spot
them again elsewhere because the light has
to now go through us and then them. And so
if you try to go further up it becomes better,
and that's why space telescopes are so useful.
But we do put telescopes on planes. One of the
telescopes that people observe is called Sofia
and it's on a plane that just the side of the
plane opens up and there's a telescope in there
and you can go on the plane as an observer
as an astronomer and observe places far away
or nearby, like you know the solar system bodies,
and you're on a plane which is not quite as good
a space but is not quite as bad as the Earth
and so you end up getting a small advantage
because you have that much less atmosphere to look
through. So we do put them on planes sometimes.
Erika Wright: As far as the ones on Earth, you'll actually
know most of them are on the tops of mountains,
right? That same issue of getting through, getting
higher and higher into the atmosphere so you're
looking through less of it. Like I said, one of
our telescopes is in Chile it's on a mountain in
Chile. Arizona, the difference between Arizona
and Cambridge is quite drastic, but we do keep
one in Cambridge just because there is the
rainy season in Arizona and there are dozens
and dozens of nights where you're just not going
to get any images, and thankfully in Cambridge
it's not quite so bad. Then it also allows us to
keep one at home that we're maintaining. Like I
said it's a 25-year-old instrument, things have to
be kept up and maintained and fixed all the time
- Oiled!
- Oiled and tweaked all the time and we have
an engineer who does all of that regularly so
that allows us to kind of have a rotating system.
- Yes, in two weeks I'm going to go up Mauna Kea,
possibly the best place to see the night sky and
the entire Earth which is why we put quite a few
telescopes there, and that's exactly that, it's
less atmosphere but it's also very dry
atmosphere so you want to try and get
as little water above you as possible, and so you
you're trying to really undo the damage that the
Earth's atmosphere does to your telescope,
so we are mostly very thankful for you know
the rain and the breathability of the planet, it
sometimes as an astronomer you wish you could just
hold your breath and not have the atmosphere
for a sec so we could take a better picture.
[#4 What Images Communicate (and how)]
A lot of the decisions that go into that, into
making the images that we see as, you know,
receivers of NASA data, the final images,
are about making it something beautiful
and understandable so a lot of times they'll
choose wavelengths, they'll choose to color
certain wavelengths in kind of the same RGB
that we think about in light that we use,
but perhaps they'll be looking at x-ray light so
they'll choose three wavelengths of x-ray light
and use that same red, green, and blue spectrum
to color it so it's a little more familiar to
our eyes. Sometimes you'll make a choice of
colorization to highlight a certain area as well,
because it's important to the data of
that object. You want people to see,
perhaps a certain star, or a certain area of gas,
and it's more about conveying the information
that is known behind it even though it's not
that color because we can't see those colors.
You know, even when we do process the images there
are choices that we make, there are decisions that
we make. It's not just a pure, you know, getting
closer to the truth process and the different
processes that we use to reduce this data, to
clean this data, try and obtain these images,
sometimes yield different results and only one of
them can be right, and that's a really difficult
thing to hold in our field of work, but it's quite
difficult for the public to feel comfortable with.
For example, I recently worked on some high
profile research looking at the clouds of Venus
to try and detect phosphine, which is here,
and if we process the data in a certain way,
phosphine shows up loud and clear but if we
process the date in a slightly different way,
not a wrong way at all, phosphine
disappears. And so the question is,
phosphine has to either be there or not, so
there is a true interpretation of these images,
and yet we don't yet know exactly what is the
right way of processing the data. The solution,
you might have guessed it, is more photons, and
so that's what I'm trying to do up on Mauna Kea
but even even us, you know, we're trying our
best and even we don't know exactly how to
process these images to get the truth out of them.
We don't know if we're creating a spurious signal
when we're cleaning out noise. We don't know if
we clean out the noise and then clean out the
signal by mistake. And so a lot goes into these
processes, and I think the public often thinks
that I'm spending my days just kind of pointing
at a star and going, "Oh, aliens on that one,
there's definitely." And it's not that. It's
mostly just looking at a lot of squiggles and
praying that the squiggles you get rid of are
noise and the squiggles you keep are truths.
[#5 Getting Results]
When when I was younger and I was starting to
figure out how to take, effectively, simulations
of the quantum behavior of molecules, I learned
all the theory, I got the supercomputer, I did all
the right things, I solved the right equations,
and I did it all and then I had to show that my
simulation, theoretical simulation, had completely
matched with true images of the spectrum of this
molecule. And it did! And it was only in
that moment when it matched that I realized,
up until that moment I didn't believe at all that
my work was real, you know? It's in the quantum
world, I had just clearly decided to be okay with
not understanding it, with it not being intuitive,
and I just didn't believe. And it was only when
I saw it, that it matched, that I trusted my own
work, I trusted that quantum physics is real, you
know. And so it was really surprising to figure
out that we, as a species, have got this far where
we can simulate the quantum world and it works!
[Subscribe and watch more from Imaging Science:]